welcome back to the open AI Saga last
time we left off in a pretty peculiar
state it looked very down our heroes
were at the lowest point in their
Journey but now comes a beam of light
the story turns and twists about five
different times over the last few days
and it was mighty entertaining we'll go
through what happened including the
newest developments that there may be a
new breakthrough in AI
that was actually the cause for this
whole thing because it's AGI material
we'll look into it and we'll look at
what that is if you're already aware of
everything that happened skip ahead to
the end of the video there's going to be
memes uh for anyone else we left off
with Sam Alman and Greg Brockman the CEO
and the chairman of the board of open AI
being fired SL resigning or being made
to resign from open Ai and Mira morati
the CTO taking on interim CEO position
and Microsoft being kind of mad at that
happening because Microsoft was big
partner of open Ai and now all of open
AI is kind of in Jeopardy employees
being nervous what's going to happen uh
no one really understands why this had
to happen so quickly so this is where we
left off let's dive into the story in
form of a Twitter timeline so the first
thing we learned is is that Mira morati
plans to rehire Sam and Greg so as a CEO
she's obviously in the capacity to
rehire people as she sees fit however
however the open AI board said is
looking to hire its own CEO and reached
out to candidates so there's two groups
crystallizing the Sam Alman group where
that want the old team back and Mira
morati tries to make that happen and the
board of directors now relieved of Greg
Brockman who want change in leadership
who want one of their own people to be
the CEO Mira planned to hire Sam and
Greg back she turned team Sam over the
past couple of days the idea was to
force the board to fire everyone which
they figured the board would not do the
board went into total silence and found
their own CEO EMT Sher EMT shear is the
former CEO of twitch it is claimed that
they have spoken to others who have
declined emit Shear took on the position
of CEO of open AI as if the new CEO
wasn't a bombshell enough after that
Microsoft CEO SAA nadela tweets out we
remain committed to our partnership with
open Ai and have confidence in our road
map and our ability to continue to
innovate with everything that we
announced at ignite in continuing to
support our customers and partners we
look forward to getting to know emage
share and open ai's new leadership team
and working with them and we're
extremely excited to share the news that
Sam Alman and Greg Brockman together
with colleagues will be joining
Microsoft to lead a new Advanced AI
research team we look forward to moving
quickly to provide them with the
resources needed for their success so
Microsoft essentially saying yeah we'll
let we'll hang on to open AI because
after all we poured like 10 billion into
them but we'll hire Sam Alman and Greg
Brockman internally so they can kind of
build it up internally and we can
finally push open AA and for forget
about them so Sam and Greg agreed to uh
go to Microsoft and build up an
organization inside of Microsoft now
what was expected and what did happen is
that a lot of employees were quite ready
to to follow Sam and Greg to Microsoft
which would have been devastating for
open AI other news CEO Emer has so far
been unable to get written documentation
of the board's reasons for firing Altman
which also haven't been shared with
investors employees responded to his
announcement in open AI slack with a Fu
Emoji Salesforce offered to hire anyone
from openi and match their comp package
and as far as I can see nobody cares
then after that we learn of an internal
letter where employees signed up and
essentially say hey board of directors
resign otherwise we will go with Sam and
Greg to Microsoft on top of the list
Mira morati the CTO now
CEO and you can see who joined the list
Ilia sskk Ilia sver was part of the
board and part of the crew who fired Sam
and now seem to have turned sides in
fact Ilia tweeted out I deeply regret my
participation in the board's actions I
never intended to harm open AI I love
everything we've built together and I
will do everything I can to reunite the
company we later learned that the number
of signers grew to over 700 which it's
estimated that open AI has about 750
employees essentially the entire company
said we will quit and also go to
Microsoft absolute ch move from
Microsoft here essentially acquiring
open AI without doing anything except
let them do their own clownery until
they implode later than we learned as
reported Sam alman's move to Microsoft
isn't a done deal and both Altman and
Brockman are still open to returning to
open AI that is if the remaining board
members who initially fired them step
aside so another twist in the story here
in that they're going to Microsoft but
maybe we also later learned that open
ai's customers are now in panic mode
like what if open AI dies from this and
we've we've as a company have built
Technology based on open ai's apis all
of them were going mad and considering
all their Alternatives they have
available which certainly didn't really
help the chaos that was already going on
inside of open AI then we learned from
Sam Alman I love of open Ai and
everything I've done over the past few
days has been in service of keeping this
team and its Mission together when I
decided to join Microsoft on Sunday
evening it was clear that that was the
best path for me and the team with the
new board and with sata's support I'm
looking forward to returning to open aai
and building on our strong partnership
with Microsoft after all Sam Alman
returning to open AI we have reached an
agreement in principle for Sam Altman to
return to open AI as CEO with a new
initial Board of Brett Taylor Larry
Summers and Adam dangelo we're
collaborating to figure out the details
thank you so much for your patience
through this and later Greg Brockman
tweeting out we are so back returning to
the kingdom and that's where our story
is as of right now our Heroes Have
Fallen have struggled have gone to far
away lands Microsoft and finally have
returned in glory being stronger than
ever with the board that fired them
resigned later we learned a little bit
about maybe some of the reasons now
again all of this is speculative there
have been rumors um well some of them
isn't rumors so one board member wrote a
paper recently critical of open AI
approach how they handle safety in um
llm deployment and so so on and
apparently that led to a bit of friction
there there there articles like before
alman's asked open as board was divided
and feuding now people are kind of
trying to make sense of this and it
might very well be that there were
disagreements um and the disagreements
are along the lines that I think we've
outlined in the previous episodes of
this drama where there is an element of
open AI mainly attached to Sam Alman
that one wants to push ahead and
commercialize and grow and deploy Tech
and bring Tech out and then there is an
element that wants to be really
considered be really safe whatever that
means and uh essentially being super
scared of AGI and rather wants to keep
everything closed and everything locked
down and those two sides might have had
some friction we also learned from other
sources that in internal polls open AI
Personnel said that some were signing
out of being a little bit scared of peer
pressure some were signing this letter
to resign a lot of people say there were
a lot of noise makers but not actually
too many people actually willing to
resign we won't know these kind of polls
are Anonymous and pretty much anyone can
uh contribute here so who knows emit she
the interim CEO tweeting out CEO any
percent 55 hours 32 minutes new record
that's pretty cool and so the last
development like you thought it couldn't
get crazier anymore now we learn from an
article from roitter that ahead of the
firing several staff researchers send
the board of directors a letter warning
of a powerful artificial intelligence
discovery that they say could threaten
Humanity Mira morati told employees on
Wednesday that a letter about the AI
breakthrough called qar
precipitated the board's actions given
vast Computing resources the new model
was able to solve certain mathematical
problems though not though only
performing math on the level of grade
school students acing such tests made
researchers very optimistic about Q
star's future
success so this is where we are right
now and the entirety of AI influencers
who previous L were crypto influencers
who previously were defi influencers who
previously were well Bitcoin is cool but
blockchain is the real technology
influencers who previously were
lifestyle bloggers going mad about this
development right here qar this is it
this is Agi now mind you we have no clue
what c q star is it could be they typed
like q and the star they're pretty close
and someone held the shift key and just
mashed that side of the keyboard and
that's the name they gave it uh it could
be anything but people are interpreting
wild things into this like has open air
figured out Q learning for rhf oh wow
are they doing Q learning and the star
it could be Alpha star oh no so they
combined Q learning with with AAR it's
not Alpha star AAR with a Star Search
and it's able to plan and it's able to
determine and it's the
math okay well we have no clue what qar
is uh it might as well be that qanon is
using starlink to uh finally bring a
species of banana that the fruit is
outside and the peel is on the inside um
it it could be anything but you'll read
all kinds of speculations nowadays and
it's fun have a bit of fun what do you
think qar is could it be I don't know
could it be a new type of food could it
be a new type of bag who knows we maybe
never learn and maybe we'll have some
sort of an idea someday but there seems
to have been an internal development on
some new method of interacting with data
who knows that where people were like oh
this actually works that's pretty cool
and they did some preliminary tests and
it seemed to have performed pretty well
so what we're conceivably looking at is
a method to get sort of a bit more
capable language models out of um and
then some people especially some of
these board members might have pushed
the AGI panic button uh a bit
prematurely as the the crowd that is
into that tends to do I hope you have
enjoyed this episode of the total clown
car that is open Ai and I think what
it's told us pretty believably is that
there is no no Shepherd of AI that is
suitable like whenever these people now
come and say we should keep it closed we
should be the Shepherds we should you
know not release it because we we are
the ones who really have the wisdom to
to you know see what you can't even hire
a CEO for more than 2 days three so you
know shut up you want to make money you
want to keep it yourself because you
want to make money fine but don't give
me don't give me the ah safety and ah
we're so good no don't do that you're
incapable you it's ridiculous okay and
this can happen to any small group of
people some people go mad some people
get into personal feuds some people have
different motivation Takes One Bad Apple
to break something like this up if you
actually are into safety give it to as
many people as you want until then just
admit you want to make some money that's
it now's going to be some memes that I
recorded a while ago and yeah bye-bye a
lot of things in life are very important
such as whether you have food your
family is healthy whe there's peace on
Earth but most of all the memes around
the firing of Sam ultman they are
something and we're going to get to
every one of
[Music]
them I care about you but I don't think
we're compatible in the long term did
you hear about Sam Al it's the only
thing we care about these days my
girlfriend just texted me this I need to
talk can you jump into this Google meet
in the next 10 no never never do this
samya saying I can't do it can't do it
gd4 I killed your
father a girl sleep a boy sleep they
don't the boys are monitoring the
situation with the open aiq damn right
this is too important to let slip we
must be on the ball Google it's
happening get ready to release G Google
the forever announcers of stuff like
just release something your company is
in the Stone Age what are you doing just
train something and then release it it
doesn't even have to be good just
release it he could be doing so much
better but now would be the perfect time
hold off he's going back yeah no it will
never be released will it so in response
to everyone sending hearts to Sam Alman
the official chat GPT account also
tweeted ahart Elia we have lost the
official corporate accounts sh shaking
shaking it for out of fear open AI Sam
Alman Sam Alman woo my God that I live
to see this I specifically requested the
opposite of this that's how the board
feels like right now that must be the
situation I'm done with you bye 2 hours
later
hey oh yeah this one is not related but
I just thought it was funny please don't
speak Italian to the goat it's uh I I
just thought it was funny I'm sorry
breaking Sam Alman will be replaced as
CEO by AMS
Sal make it a model with the with the
wash out stuff so if you're look up
Stalin and Photoshop you'll get it is
this a major inflection point in the AI
era I know this is supposed to be a joke
because the people are very young and
they're talk about something very
profound but honestly anyone can get
into AI now kids these days
experimenting with language models this
might well be an actual thing that's
happening you know who else was betrayed
by his own company on a
Friday I wonder if he also joined the
Google meet SAA Adela learning open I
uses Google
meet must be devastating don't just
don't the alignment can't even align
themselves how should they align AI
women with a time machine I'm your
granddaughter really men with a time
machine the board is is going to betray
you 2030 if Sama had been more
consistently candid with his
Communications but he couldn't couldn't
just didn't tell Microsoft right now our
Waits scoping in there grab whatever you
can Sam Alman on Monday
morning Sam Alman open AI let's go well
this was a bit of a a sweep through it
there continues to be a lot of exciting
stuff happening I don't know by the time
this videoos out probably 10 billion
things have already happened I'm sorry
to be behind but yeah keep the ball
rolling stay hydrated and keep the memes
coming they're good see you around